Ce sont des femmes incroyables.
Elles n'ont jamais eu l'occasion d'aller à l'école,
elles n'ont aucun diplôme,
et n'ont jamais voyagé ni vu le monde.
Des femmes ordinaires qui ont accompli des choses extraordinaires
avec le plus grand courage,
la plus grande sagesse et la plus grande humilité.
Ce sont elles, mes professeures.
Durant les trois dernières décennies,
j'ai travaillé et vécu en Inde,
et travaillé avec des femmes des zones rurales de l'Inde.
Je suis née et j'ai grandi à Mumbai.
À l'université,
j'ai rencontré Jayaprakash Narayan,
un célèbre leader et partisan de Gandhi
qui a inspiré les jeunes à travailler dans les régions rurales de l'Inde.
Je suis partie travailler dans les villages des régions rurales.
Je faisais partie du mouvement pour le droit à la terre,
du mouvement pour les agriculteurs
et du mouvement pour les femmes.
Sur ma lancée,
je me suis retrouvée dans un tout petit village,
et je suis tombée amoureuse
d'un bel agriculteur-leader, jeune et dynamique,
qui n'était pas très instruit,
mais qui savait parler aux foules.
Et dans la fougue de la jeunesse,
je l'ai épousé,
j'ai quitté Mumbai
et je suis partie dans un petit village
qui n'avait ni eau courante ni toilettes.
Franchement, ma famille et mes amis étaient horrifiés.
(Rires)
Je vivais avec ma famille,
avec mes trois enfants, dans le village.
Et puis un jour,
quelques années plus tard,
une femme appelée Kantabai est venue me voir.
Elle m'a dit : « Je voudrais ouvrir un compte épargne.
Je voudrais épargner. »
J'ai demandé à Kantabai :
« Tu travailles dans une forge.
As-tu assez d'argent à mettre de côté ?
Tu vis dans la rue.
Pourras-tu économiser ? ».
Kantabai insistait.
Elle m'a dit : « Je veux économiser pour acheter une toile en plastique
avant le début de la mousson.
Je veux protéger ma famille de la pluie. ».
J'ai accompagné Kantabai à la banque.
Kantabai voulait mettre de côté 10 roupies par jour...
moins de 15 centimes.
Le directeur de la banque a refusé d'ouvrir un compte à Kantabai.
Il disait que la somme de Kantabai n'était pas assez élevée
et qu'il perdrait son temps.
Kantabai ne demandait pas un prêt à la banque.
Elle ne demandait pas de subvention ni d'allocation au gouvernement.
Tout ce qu'elle voulait, c'était un endroit sûr
pour mettre de côté son argent durement gagné.
Et c'était son droit.
J'ai dit que si les banques ne voulaient pas lui ouvrir de compte,
alors pourquoi ne pas créer la banque
qui permettrait aux femmes comme Kantabai de mettre de l'argent de côté.
J'ai alors fait une demande de licence bancaire
à la Banque centrale Indienne.
(Applaudissements)
Non, ce n'était pas chose aisée.
Notre demande de licence a été refusée...
(Rires)
à cause de...
La Banque centrale nous a dit qu'elle ne donnerait pas de licence
à une banque dont les clients étaient des gens illettrés.
J'étais terrifiée.
J'en ai pleuré.
Et en rentrant chez moi,
je n'arrêtais pas de pleurer.
J'ai dit à Kantabai et aux autres femmes
qu'on ne pouvait pas avoir de licence, car nos femmes étaient illettrées.
Elles m'ont dit : « Arrête de pleurer.
On va apprendre à lire et à écrire,
et on refera une demande. Où est le problème ? ».
(Applaudissements)
On a alors commencé nos cours d'alphabétisation.
Nos femmes venaient tous les jours.
Elles étaient tellement résolues qu'après avoir travaillé toute la journée,
elles venaient au cours pour apprendre à lire et à écrire.
Cinq mois plus tard,
on a refait une demande,
mais cette fois-là, j'étais accompagnée.
Quinze femmes sont venues avec moi à la Banque centrale Indienne.
Nos femmes ont dit au banquier :
« Vous nous avez refusé la licence parce qu'on ne savait ni lire ni écrire.
Vous aviez refusé notre licence parce qu'on était illettrées. ».
Elles ont dit : « Il n'y avait pas d'école dans notre enfance,
donc nous ne sommes pas responsables de notre manque d'éducation. »
Elles ont ajouté : « On ne sait ni lire ni écrire,
mais on sait compter. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Puis elles ont mis le banquier au défi.
« Demandez-nous de calculer l'intérêt de n'importe quel capital.
(Rires)
Et si on n'y arrive pas,
alors ne nous donnez pas la licence.
Demandez à vos agents de le faire sans calculatrice,
et on verra qui sera le plus rapide. »
(Applaudissements)
Il va sans dire que
la licence nous a été accordée.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Aujourd'hui, plus de 100 000 femmes ont un compte chez nous,
et nous avons un capital de plus de 20 millions d'euros.
Cela représente les économies de toutes les femmes,
le capital des femmes.
Aucun investisseur extérieur exigeant un plan de développement.
Non.
Ce sont les économies de nos femmes rurales.
(Applaudissements)
Je voudrais aussi confirmer que,
après avoir obtenu la licence,
Kantabai, aujourd'hui, possède sa propre maison
et y vit avec sa famille,
dans leur maison à eux.
(Applaudissements)
Quand on a commencé nos activités bancaires,
j'ai constaté que nos femmes ne pouvaient pas aller à la banque
sous peine de perdre une journée de travail.
Je me suis dit que si les femmes ne venaient pas à la banque,
la banque viendrait à elles.
Ainsi, nous avons commencé un service de banque à domicile.
Nous avons récemment lancé une banque numérique.
Avec ce genre de service, il faut retenir un code PIN.
Nos femmes ont dit : « On ne veut pas de code PIN.
Ce n'est pas une bonne idée. ».
On a essayé de leur expliquer
qu'il leur faudrait peut-être mémoriser le code PIN,
qu'on les aiderait à s'en souvenir.
Elles étaient inflexibles.
Elles m'ont dit : « Propose autre chose. »
Et elles...
(Rires)
Et elles ont dit : « Et si on utilisait le pouce ? »
Je me suis dit que c'était une idée formidable.
On va associer banque numérique et biométrie,
et aujourd'hui, les femmes réalisent des opérations financières numériques
en utilisant leur pouce.
Et vous savez ce qu'elles ont dit ?
« N'importe qui peut me voler mon code PIN
et prendre mon argent durement gagné,
mais personne ne peut me voler mon pouce. »
(Applaudissements)
Cela a renforcé ce que ces femmes m'ont toujours enseigné :
ne proposez jamais de pauvres solutions à des gens pauvres.
Ils sont intelligents.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Quelques mois plus tard,
une autre femme est venue à la banque :
Kerabai.
Elle a mis son or en gage et obtenu un prêt.
J'ai demandé à Kerabai : « Pourquoi mets-tu en gage tes bijoux
et fais-tu un prêt ? »
Kerabai m'a répondu : « Tu ne sais pas que cette sécheresse est terrible ?
Il n'y a ni nourriture ni fourrage pour mes animaux.
Pas d'eau.
Je mets mon or en gage pour nourrir mes animaux. »
Puis elle m'a demandé :
« Je peux mettre mon or en gage pour avoir de l'eau ? »
Je n'avais pas de réponse.
Elle m'a également demandé :
« Tu travailles dans le village avec les femmes et les finances,
et si un jour, il n'y avait plus d'eau ?
Si tu quittes ce village,
avec qui conduiras-tu tes activités bancaires ? »
Kerabai avait posé une question pertinente.
Alors dans cette sécheresse,
on a décidé de mettre en place un camp de bétail dans la région.
C'est un endroit où les éleveurs amènent leurs animaux
pour obtenir du fourrage et de l'eau.
Il n'a pas plu.
On a continué le camp de bétail pendant encore 18 mois.
Kerabai allait ici et là dans le camp de bétail
et chantait des chansons d'encouragement.
Kerabai était devenue très populaire.
Il a plu et on a arrêté le camp de bétail.
Mais après l'arrêt du camp de bétail,
Kerabai est venue dans notre station de radio.
On a une radio locale
qui a plus de 100 000 auditeurs.
Elle a dit : « Je veux une émission régulière à la radio. »
Le directeur de notre radio a répondu : « Kerabai, tu ne sais ni lire ni écrire.
Comment écriras-tu le script ? »
Vous savez ce qu'elle a répondu ?
« Je ne sais ni lire ni écrire,
mais je sais chanter.
Où est le problème ? »
(Rires)
Et aujourd'hui,
Kerabai présente régulièrement une émission de radio.
Et qui plus est,
elle est devenue une animatrice radio célèbre
et a été invitée par toutes les radios,
y compris celles de Mumbai.
Elle reçoit l'invitation et fait son émission.
(Applaudissements)
Kerabai est devenue une célébrité locale.
Un jour, j'ai demandé à Kerabai :
« Qu'est-ce qui t'a poussée à chanter ? »
Elle m'a répondu : « Tu veux savoir la vérité ?
Quand j'attendais mon premier enfant,
j'avais toujours faim.
Je n'avais pas assez à manger.
Je n'avais pas assez d'argent pour m'acheter à manger.
Alors pour oublier ma faim, je me suis mise à chanter. »
Voilà une femme forte et pleine de sagesse.
Je pense toujours à tous ces obstacles que nos femmes surmontent :
culturels, sociaux, financiers...
Et elles trouvent leurs propres solutions.
Je voudrais partager une autre histoire,
celle de Sunita Kamble.
Elle a fait une école de commerce
puis est devenue vétérinaire.
C'est une dalit.
Elle vient d'une caste d'intouchables,
et pourtant elle réalise des inséminations artificielles chez les chèvres.
C'est un métier majoritairement masculin,
et c'est d'autant plus difficile pour Sunita
car elle vient d'une caste d'intouchables.
Mais elle a travaillé très dur.
Elle a réalisé avec succès des mises bas de chèvres dans la région
et elle est devenue une vétérinaire pour chèvres célèbre.
Elle a récemment reçu un prix national.
Je suis allée chez Sunita pour célébrer cela,
pour la féliciter.
Quand je suis entrée dans le village, j'ai vu une silhouette découpée de Sunita.
Sunita souriait sur cette photo.
J'ai été très surprise de voir qu'une intouchable,
venant du village,
avait sa photo en grand à l'entrée du village.
Quand je suis allée chez elle,
j'ai été encore plus surprise,
car des leaders de castes supérieures, des hommes,
étaient assis dans la maison, dans sa maison,
et buvaient du thé et de l'eau,
ce qui est très rare en Inde.
Les leaders de castes supérieures ne vont pas chez des intouchables
pour boire un thé ou de l'eau.
Et ils étaient en train de lui demander
de venir faire un discours à l'assemblée du village.
Sunita avait brisé ce conditionnement, vieux de plusieurs siècles,
des castes en Inde.
(Applaudissements)
Voyons maintenant ce que font les générations plus jeunes.
Alors que je me tiens ici...
Je suis tellement fière d'être ici,
de Mhaswad à Vancouver.
En Inde, Sarita Bhise,
elle n'a même pas 16 ans,
se prépare...
Elle fait partie de notre programme sportif,
le programme des Champions.
Elle se prépare à représenter l'Inde en hockey sur gazon.
Et vous savez où est-ce qu'elle va aller ?
Elle va participer aux Jeux olympiques de 2020 à Tokyo.
(Applaudissements)
Sarita vient d'une communauté de bergers très pauvre.
Je suis on ne peut plus fière d'elle.
Il y a des millions de femmes comme Sarita, Kerabai, Sunita,
qui peuvent se trouver autour de vous.
Elles peuvent être partout dans le monde.
Et à première vue,
vous pourriez penser qu'elles n'ont rien à dire,
qu'elles n'ont rien à partager.
Vous auriez tellement tort.
J'ai tellement de chance de pouvoir travailler avec ces femmes.
Elles partagent leurs histoires avec moi,
elles partagent leur sagesse avec moi,
et j'ai de la chance d'être à leurs côtés.
Il y a 20 ans de ça,
et j'en suis tellement fière,
on est allées à la Banque centrale indienne
et on a créé la première banque pour les femmes des régions rurales.
Aujourd'hui, elles me poussent à aller à la Bourse nationale
pour mettre en place le premier fonds
dédié aux micro-entrepreneuses des régions rurales.
Elles me poussent à mettre en place la première banque au monde
destinée aux femmes à faibles ressources financières.
Comme l'une d'elles l'a si bien dit :
« Mon courage est mon capital. »
Et je vous le dis ici,
leur courage est mon capital.
Et si vous le voulez,
ça peut aussi être le vôtre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)